[Music]
[Music]
PlayStation VR always had a tough road
ahead of it very high-end gaming pcs
needed to power the oculus rift in HTC
vive the PlayStation 4 is underpowered
the fact that Sony was retrofitting it
sold 2010 released move controllers and
PlayStation camera to work with psvr
which were peripherals that weren't
initially designed for vo are also does
not bode well for the platform after
going eyes on with it for the past few
days and must admit that it surprisingly
impressed it in some areas but it also
has some issues one area where psvr
could use improvement is with resolution
the visuals unfortunately look a little
blurry the head-mounted display uses a
5.7 inch 1920 by 1080 resolution
stereoscopic 3d screen while 1080p is
fine on a TV that's several feet in
front of you it's a whole different
story when the display is magnified in
front of your eyes PSV are also supports
a hundred twenty Hertz refresh rate
panel which allows the hmd to render up
to 120 frames per second having a high
frame rate is essential in VR because
when the frame rate dips too low VR
nausea may start to kick in poor head
tracking can also lead to view our
motion sickness luckily that isn't a
problem here PS VR has nine positional
tracking LEDs on the hmd and features
just 18 milliseconds of latency the
headset itself may look bulky but it
feels really light despite wing 1.3
pounds it helps that the weight of psvr
is bounce from the front to the back its
overall Organon makes it the most
comfortable HMV to wear psvr supplies
its own earbuds and supports 3d audio
which coupled with positional head
tracking does a great job enhancing the
immersion of the arm it is important to
note that psvr requires a PlayStation
camera which is sold separately from the
base package furthermore to get the full
VR experience and to get your hands into
VR you're gonna want to get Sony's Move
controllers which are also sold
separately
psvr can deliver some incredibly
immersive experiences aspiring a passive
experience a shark encounter which is a
short demo within the PlayStation VR
worlds compilation can be riveting it
virtually places you in a shark cage and
anchors you deep down into the ocean
when you encounter a massive great white
shark that's out to eat you seeing it
pry open your cage with its sharp teeth
provides a sense of danger that is
impossible to replicate on a traditional
display the London heist is also another
psvr highlight seeing a mobster point
the barrel of his gun at your head is
unnerving but in the coolest way being
able to shoot back at gangsters is also
wildly fun
one concern that I had going into this
review is whether or not the move
controllers would be accurate enough for
VR but they do a surprisingly good job
of tracking your hands while there's a
lot to like about psvr it also has
issues the PlayStation camera has a
relatively small field of view and
you'll lose tracking if either your
controller or headset pops outside of
its fov also when I stepped more than
eight feet away from the camera
everything started to awkwardly shift in
and out it's not the end of the world by
any means but it definitely feels like
an ecosystem that's cobbled together
using existing parts furthermore because
psvr only uses one camera the move
controllers will get included if you
turn completely around as the camera
needs to see the light emitting from the
controller to track it what this means
on a fundamental level is that we are
likely not to get 360 experiences it's
also unfortunate that the Move
controllers don't have a d-pad or
movement stick as this further limits
PSP RS capabilities
despite all these little technical
deficiencies the biggest issue plaguing
psvr is motion sickness your mileage may
vary here as some people don't have
issues with dr nausea i unfortunately
i'm not one of them many of the
first-person launch games made me feel
ill the main culprit here is artificial
locomotion this is when a game binds
first-person movement to a joystick
while this is fine on a flat-screen TV
in VR your eyes are tricked into
thinking your body is moving but your
body does not get the same cues this
disconnect can lead to wobbly sea legs
sony tells me that gamers should take
15-minute breaks each hour to combat
motion sickness but that's not a very
good long-term solution while PSP r is
cheaper than either the rift or the vive
and doesn't require an expensive pc
there is a reason that high-quality VR
is expensive sure PS VR is more
affordable but it also takes some
shortcuts while it sometimes works
surprisingly well given its constraints
it reminds me of the adage you get what
you pay for as the VR fan I want psvr to
succeed but it trips up a bit too much
too wholeheartedly recommend right now
if you have a ps4 and are dying to get
pious VR then I'd recommend the $500
bundle which includes the PlayStation
camera to move controllers and
PlayStation VR worlds if you have a ps4
and are simply curious about the R I'd
hold off until more titles are released
for everyone else I'd recommend saving
up for a better reality for more gaming
and hardware coverage stay tuned to gain
spot calm and subscribe to our YouTube
channel
[Music]